well internet you've joined us here amid
a decision-making moment we're deciding
whether or not to go through with this
video this is highly suggested and it's
it's a tongue in a mousetrap I don't I
don't do it I know I wouldn't wanna do
it either and the thing is this the
smallest mousetrap possible and it still
packs an absolute wallet it's brutal
look at it oh yeah
it's literally smashed the plastic
bitter really yeah look it's now gone
well I like that the tongue is the last
place I want thankfully apart from maybe
there's two reasons your tongue isn't
made of plastic and it is the strongest
muscle in the body so am i right
it'll look quali God's sake any reason
you're not doing it Jim knows you're
getting away ah well ah Sh
alright so we're rolling at 2,000 frames
a second in HD and uh Dan has been
pacing ever since we finished the intro
understandably
be my tongues over look Abby what stupid
looks like it's having a really really
dangerous oyster shut up I can't reach
it
you over there ah no no don't you bad oh
so gross yeah he's sucking it out like
give me my tongue ah
honestly I can't believe you did that
that was impressive
I'm impressed birth mile about three not
a bad man well if you suggested that
video you know who you are and you
probably feel quite guilty so if you see
Dan won't you buy him a drink unless
you're wearing a slow-mo shirt and then
Dan will buy you a drink
I've still doing it yeah that way well
usually I say all this stuff at the end
of the video or the call to action but
then why don't you do this one so later
by to set the top subscribe force on
flipper I blink bye I'll see in the next
video so a guy